hello friends and welcome to another GS
news update if you're trying to avoid
Star Wars spoilers then don't worry this
news update is one hundred percent Star
Wars free the first retail edition of
PlayStation VR will require an external
processing unit that has been estimated
to be roughly the same size as
nintendo's wii console PlayStation VR
units will use the external processor to
ease the burden of rendering virtual
reality graphics the headset will plug
directly into the unit which in turn is
connected to the ps4 according to a
polygon report pictures of the device
were not permitted when demonstrated at
a recent games event but from memory the
reporter claims the device is a bit
smaller than a way PlayStation VR
previously codenamed Morpheus represents
the corporation's big gamble in the
revived virtual reality market despite
its development stretch now entering its
third year a final price has yet to be
set this is true two of Sony's rivals
and virtual reality such as oculus VR
bought by Facebook and VV are delayed to
2016 it appears none of the three key
competitors are ready to set a price
point for the luxury peripheral with
costs considered a key obstruction to
mass market adoption are you thinking of
getting PlayStation VR let us know in
the comments below or come and find me
on Twitter and how not to draw i'm kate
and thanks for watching